[Music]  once you do the work of learning about  happiness  that's when it really gets interesting  because the second part the second stage  is applying it to your life  you got to understand it but then you  got to practice it everything is about  practice look you can read a book about  golf but you can't play golf unless you  get out there and play and the same  thing is true of happiness you're going  to learn a whole lot about happiness in  this class but then you got to practice  it and we'll give you the exercises that  you need so you can do the practice and  and then the beautiful part comes in  because you'll be ready to  to teach it then you'll be able to help  others to become happier and when you do  that then it's locked in forever in your  life  [Music]